[Música]
ah
año 1600 un campamento de ti piso
nativos americanos para todos indios
al amanecer una partida de caza
tres indios un cazador un explorador y
el líder un rastreador salen por un
bosque el líder el rastreador de repente
no está algo percibe algo en el ambiente
un cambio mira el suelo y ve unas
huellas
se acerca las observa las toca
se levanta y da la información son tres
personas dos hombres y una mujer la
mujer mérida han pasado justo antes del
amanecer y se dirigen hacia el norte
no es magia
el rastreo poder leer el terreno e
interpretarlo como si hubieras estado
viendo directamente allí
como si abres la página de un libro y
lees interpretas todo lo que ha pasado
eso es rastrear
los idiomas se componen por signos por
palabras por letras por frases el
rastreo se forma con huellas rastros y
señales
la gente pregunta qué es un rastreador
que es el rastreo
yo hago cosas sencillas 3 observó
tengo paciencia y uso sentido común
todos vosotros sois rastreadores
hasta dónde podemos llegar hasta donde
queramos hasta donde nuestra motivación
y nuestro conocimiento nos ponga por ver
esta señal en el terreno
una huella
pero podemos leer más es una huella de
un lobo de una hembra alfa por la forma
elíptica que tiene los dedos las uñas y
además sabemos qué ha pasado después del
amanecer por la mañana ha llovido la
gota se han caído en el terno y han
dejado unas pequeñas señales el lobo con
la pata ha pisado después y ha hecho
este efecto
a comprimir el terreno y después ha
levantado lo ha descomprimido ya genera
unos relieves esos relieves conforman un
dibujo que da al agua ya una
caracterización de que eso es un lobo
es el lobo en concreto y además sabemos
que por la huella que está limpia por
dentro ha pisado la lluvia y sabemos que
es reciente es la información que
podemos sacar
desde ahora lo llevamos haciendo
millones de años exactamente en más de 2
millones de años ya el homo erectus era
capaz de llegar a un lugar y conectar
con el ambiente porque porque entendió
cuando vio una huella que si seguía esa
huella le podía llevar a comer oa beber
agua pero también durante ese período
que iba rastreando tenía que estar
alerta porque había otros animales que
lo podrían cazar hemos sufrido en todos
los entornos en selvas en desiertos en
ecosistemas nevados en montañas y en
todos ellos en el recorrido que hemos
hecho hemos ido aprendiendo e
interpretando el entorno pero ahora no
lo hacemos porque porque estamos
desconectados de hablamos de rastreo no
viene la imagen siempre de culturas
ancestrales
aborígenes bosquimanos del kalahari
indios y coa ni en la selva amazónica
tengo que decir que esta fascinación por
interpretar y ver todo lo que ha
ocurrido es lo que me ha llevado durante
más de 10 años a recorrer el mundo
aprendiendo de culturas ancestrales de
orígenes de fuerzas especiales pero
también de pastores de mi pueblo de mi
padre de mi madre y sobre todo de mi
compañera paloma otra fantástica
rastreadora
es muy interesante porque desde cuando
creéis que empezamos a rastrear lo
sabéis alguno
o lo imagináis
empezamos a rastrear derretir el momento
que nacemos lo primero que buscamos no
son huellas es el calor de nuestra madre
lo primero que hacemos es buscar y
localizar el pezón para poder tomar el
primer sorbo de vida desde ahí ese
primer rastreo hasta el final hasta que
morimos rastreamos
ya lo decía un famoso rastreador
americano tom brown cuando alguien mueve
algo en tu casa tú lo sabes cuando
alguien mueve algo en el bosque yo lo sé
nos movemos por patrones y si esos
patrones cambian los detectamos lo
hacemos todos los días aunque no nos
demos cuenta por ejemplo cuando entró mi
despacho
tengo un marco con un corcho en el que
pegó mi esposita todos de color rojo con
letras y frases y un día entró al
despacho y de repente mi visión
periférica me alerta de que algo hay
diferente ahí ha sido mi mujer a coloca
un post-it de color amarillo y dibuja un
corazón y lo noto pero curioso está en
cuando llego a casa y marc el fin de
semana segovia porque llevé un pamplona
ella tiene una radio permita la cocina y
arriba hay un enchufe esto es nuevo en
la radio y coloco mi móvil para cargarlo
intento después cuando lo saco coloca la
radio como estaba pero mi madre detecta
incluso que la radio no está
perfectamente colocada en mí dice
descarga el móvil llevo si esos son los
patrones
y es muy importante porque porque lo
tenemos que tener en cuenta a día de hoy
aquí y ahora tenemos que cambiar y
tenemos que empezar a observar y vamos a
hacer cuando salgamos fuera observar
conectar perdón reconectar porque aunque
el rastreo pensemos que está arraigado
ahí están muy superficialmente lo
hacemos todos los días y si no lo
hubieran hecho nuestros ancestros no
estaríamos aquí hoy porque porque
tenemos que tener sentido de alerta
tenemos que tener un poquito de energía
porque eso nos hace estar atentos a lo
que nos rodea
hay quien cruza el bosque y solo de
línea para fuego pero chicos el bosque
está mudo en east asia o está lleno de
vida pero vamos así en un efecto túnel y
no vemos lo que tenemos alrededor ya que
observar lo que tenemos aquí lo que
tenemos aquí y lo que tenemos a la
lejanía
si ellos no lo hubieran hecho en
cualquier entorno de estos y hubieran
evolucionado observando en estado alerta
nos hubieran comido
a aquellos que han sido atentos aquellos
que no se lo hayan rastreado han hecho
que tras generación tras generación son
genes y esa esencia vuelva estar aquí lo
que tenemos que hacer es volver a sentir
y volver a los orígenes es difícil y yo
lo sé porque en ciudades como las que
estamos en ciudades tan modernas como
shanghai como uruguay o como singapur
creas artificiales bonitas preciosas con
grandes edificios
no nos permiten volver a los orígenes
aunque sí que utilizáis el rastreo
seguimos utilizando señales nos ponemos
al lado de un paso peatones y vemos
señales blancas que nos indican por
dónde pasar vamos a pasar un coche
estamos con el walkman estamos con el
móvil guasave ando y de repente que
ocurre va a pasar un coche y frenamos
paramos en seco pasa el coche uff casi
eso quien no esas contracciones en la
selva cuando hacemos los desiertos y
ahora lo hacemos en la jungla
y ahora miramos al cielo para saber qué
tiempo va a hacer
de hecho hay indicios que todos
sufrimos empezamos nos sentimos cansados
está bajando la presión es un indicio
primitivo que nos está avisando que
cuando salimos de la caverna mete
adentro y no vayas a salir a cazar
mamuts porque va quedar una tormenta la
tecnología es buena pero usándola en su
justa medida
ponemos una fotografía de un móvil para
hacer una huella o una bota y poder
utilizar una búsqueda una persona como
raros como rastreador profesional lo uso
pero no es lo que hay que hacer hay que
usarla en su justa medida porque tenemos
el equipo básico los sentidos y además
tenemos para subir mucha información en
la nube pero por un momento olvidemos la
tecnología
pongámonos en modo recepción y qué es
eso muy simple nos colocamos
nos paramos y empezamos a recibir
información del ambiente a través de
nuestros sentidos y empezaremos a captar
un montón de información que antes para
nosotros no existía
somos visuales está claro y un
rastreador lo que más usa es la vista
pasamos por un entorno como puede ser
este podemos pasar por un entorno al que
está vacío pero de repente si observamos
hay un patrón diferente nos encontramos
con un animal por ejemplo una marmota y
como esto miles de ejemplos
importantísimo usar nuestros sentidos
achar tocar sentir
yo tengo en cuenta incluso cuando voy
por el bosque mediterráneo y voy a pisar
una planta aromática
yo voy andando la piso
y el montón de sustancias volátiles pero
el corzo que estaba pastando y le llega
con un choque olor se va todo hay que
tenerlo en cuenta pero escuchar también
es muy importante vamos a hacer un
ejercicio todo es decir eco
otra vez
vale y ahora abrimos un poquito la
mandíbula y cogemos las manos y las
colocamos de esta manera y cerramos un
poquito los dedos y decimos echo
otra vez echo
qué tal escucháis mucho mejor sencillo
hicimos utilizando nuestras técnicas
pero bien atentos
ah
un macho frenético de carbón y una
hembra que está oyendo esto es uno de
los miles de ejemplos de puede entender
unos sonidos en naturaleza
el petirrojo me encanta estoy en mi
escritorio trabajando el ordenador y
suena en el jardín tranquilamente
y de repente se hacer algo un porsche
qué ocurre mi vecino pasea con el perro
y cuando llega justo dónde está el
petirrojo se acelera y él me dice que
está pasando el vecino sin verlo pero si
tengo que hablar de aliados hablo de
este pájaro la barraca me encanta la
vaca está fuera
y de repente llama otro rack yo estoy la
cocina preparando el desayuno
y otra repente vamos dando las 3
y sé para qué me están indicando un gato
se acerca al aporte a mi casa cogen el
macetero y se cagan literalmente allí y
las urracas me avisan y además yo abro
la puerta asustó al gato el gato se va y
las vacas van a comerse la comida gato
que le pone la vecina
pero
estamos en peligro
el drástico sin prestar la realidad y
tenemos que asumirla para que para poner
soluciones a partir de ahora de aquí
cuando seamos fuera
me encanta la forma salvaje me encantan
los ecosistemas me encanta la protección
de los animales y sus entornos no lo
discuto igual que muchos de vosotros
incluso a ellos los orangutanes que son
los más cercanos a nosotros pero nuestra
huella nuestra propia esencia está en
peligro
debemos de retomar el camino correcto
seguir la senda nunca mejor dicho y
empezar a sentir y volver a los orígenes
porque el rastreo beneficioso el rastreo
está que sería el campo escuchar sentir
utilizar nuestros sentidos el cerebro
que era preguntas hipótesis que nos
hacen que funcionemos hacer ejercicio
físico
y para ello
vamos a conectar y por momentos voy a
regalar un minuto en la selva de sumatra
todos
todos ellos
[Música]
2 medidas
todos los días
[Música]
no
un regalo en el tiempo no hace falta ir
salir la de sumatra en cualquier lugar
incluso sumándose por la ventana
sellando el jardín de casa al de la
urbanización oa cualquier lugar cerca de
nuestra ciudad podemos conectar
siguientes para observar percibir y
disfrutar
ellos están conectados de hecho me
sorprendió con 2000 sumatra porque
cuando llueve cuando granizo
ellos salen ellos interaccionan y
disfrutan
ahora en nuestra cultura de hoy en día
'la unión' es el único que se dice es no
toques no salgas no te mojes no te subas
ven aquí no te manches y ellos son la
clave si queremos cambiar esto tengo que
tener soluciones y la clave está ahí en
ellos que cojan y toquen el suelo que se
toquen sienta en la tierra que se
manchen de barro que cojan elementos del
campo piedras palos que hagan formas que
su cerebro trabaje con los elementos
naturales
hay que dejarles
que suban por los árboles que se llenen
de barro con adornos con plumas con
pajas hay que dejarles que sean niños
porque nosotros cuando arrastramos
volvemos a ser niños y esa es nuestra
propia esencia es muy importante muy muy
importante
un viendo una alarma
significa que hay algo
se ha ido qué será
a seguir por ahí el mismo
[Aplausos]
ah